President Cyril Ramaphosa has determined Wednesday,
May 29th as a date for the 2024 general
national and provincial elections.
Now the announcement is in accordance
with the Constitution of South Africa.
The president says he has a
consulted with the Electoral Commission
of South Africa on the election date.
A furthermore,
Ramaphosa says he has convened a meeting with all nine
provincial premiers
and the IEC to discuss the stage of readiness
for the general elections.
Now the 2024 elections coincide with South Africa's
Celebration of 30 years of freedom and democracy.
Therefore, President Ramaphosa has called on all
eligible voters to fully participate
in this important and historic
milestone on the South Africa democratic calendar.